starting off this hour is mani in
Maryland hi many welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey Dave how's it going
better than I deserve what's up okay so
I'm 20 years old originally from
California I met my girlfriend there she
lived in Maryland and I moved in with
her about a year ago we recently got an
apartment together and well things
didn't work out we broke up and we're
gonna be living together until our lease
is up in June I'm on baby step two I
have about three thousand dollars left
my question is whether I I'm planning on
moving back to California in June when
our lease is up and my question is
whether I continue paying debt or start
piling a cash for the move What's it
cost to move I'm not quite sure the the
plane ticket it's probably not going to
be that much but I mean I don't have
much stuff here the only thing I have is
like a guitar sounds like so far but do
what yeah okay so far but probably not
gonna end up moving that yeah probably
not
yeah it'll cost more to move it to
California than it's worth right okay so
you need a plane ticket mm-hmm so what
do you make about 25,000 mm-hmm and what
did you make in California same thing
aren't you going to go to California now
I wouldn't live in an apartment of
somebody broke up with that's crazy
world man that's just weird innit
it is yeah I mean God man my hair is
crawling up the back of my neck and it's
not even me I don't even want to be I
don't even want to stay in the same
house for sharing when we have a good
fight much less live again we broke up
yeah the reason I was thinking about
that was because wouldn't it like hurt
I've heard it hurts like you're like
credit I guess to break a leaf I wasn't
breaking the law you still got to pay it
where are you gonna live in California
I'm probably gonna find an apartment
with one of my friends okay
are your parents there they are but
they're living in an RV oh well that's
not convenient either yeah well I gotta
tell you man I'll be trying to figure
out a way to get out of there I'm not
talking about the math I'm just talking
about the weird if I'm you I you got to
have thought of that I mean this is it's
painful mm-hmm isn't it yeah okay so
what does she make um she makes probably
a little bit more than me because she
has two jobs mm-hmm and what would your
apartment what would your apart What's
it cost there I'd ask that to lit here
yeah what's your apartment cost 1,200 a
month so you're paying 600 yeah how much
of that would she pick up if she could
get rid of you if you picked up 300 and
she picked up another 300 would she do
that to get rid of you what do you mean
would she go to 900 and you pay 300 if
you agreed to leave now
and leave her the couch maybe yeah and
then you take that 300 and pay it from
California and take the other 300 and
use that to split with a roommate in a
cheap way and get on over there you just
put your entire life on hold for six
months in a weird way and if I'm you I'm
trying to figure out some way that's
legal moral finishes the lease doesn't
leave her hanging we're not trying to be
and lack of nobility with her leave her
the couch you know what could I pay you
to let me go away you know that kind of
a thing and you know then I'm out of
there yeah you guys are just nicer than
hillbillies hillbillies we would we
wouldn't be able to do this I couldn't
like the way I grew up you can't my
brain didn't work this way I'm not this
nice
so you're a nice person but um Wow yeah
I just do what you want to do but I'm
trying to figure a way to get on out of
there now
and it only costs you a plane ticket you
can scratch that together go take go
take an extra job delivering pizzas and
clean up this for a little while work
work more than 40 hours go ahead and
work 60 hours and that's an extra 1,500
a month and you can pull this together
come up with a plane ticket give her up
maybe give her a handful of dollars and
just walk off and a lump sum I don't
know but whatever whatever deal you can
work with her anything is you have to
make sure the lease does get completed
by her because if she doesn't complete
the lease properly and leave the
property in good condition you they
could come after you for either the lack
of rent payment or tearing up the
property so you want to be sure she's
not gonna do that but yeah I assume I'm
assuming that that's all that if you're
able to live together surely you can
pull that part off so Wow okay